auf diesem Kanal habe ich euch lange
nicht so begrüßt wie es eigentlich
verdient habe
ist ein Tage durchs Internet gesurft
um die besten Sommer und strandgadgets
im Internet zu finden und wenn ich
Internet sage und meine ich Amazon was
soll ich sonst machen und natürlich
mache ich das nicht im Küchen Slash
Wohnzimmer Slash Essbereich sondern am
See ja hallo ja Vanessa vom See hier hi
und wie ist das Wetter ja das Wetter
fantastisch wir haben Sonne und viele
nackte Menschen unser erstes Gadget hat
eigentlich nicht so viel mit Wasserspaß
zu tun aber es ist etwas was viele Leute
am Strand machen mit einem
Metalldetektor den Strand absuchen
3.557 Bewertung und 4,3 Sterne und ob
sich die Investition von 27,99 gelohnt
haben sehen wir jetzt ich denke wirklich
gerade Loki dass ich viel Geld verdienen
werde ich meine wir sind am See die
Leute haben doch hier bestimmt oft
Kleingeld oder Schmuck verloren
peinlich 90 peinlich aber ich hätte
lieber so lange stark gebraucht muss ich
nämlich so würdelos
aber das hat ja überhaupt keine ratio
weißt du ich muss ja wirklich mit diesem
Punkt den ganzen Sandstrand absuchen ich
habe eine neue Technik entwickelt
oh wow was ist das denn oh ja da
reagiert das muss echtes Silber sein
reagiert
so lange gel
aufen das Ding ist scheiße
noch ein Korken vielleicht hätte ich
mehr Spaß gehabt wenn ich wirklich etwas
gefunden hätte und nicht nur Kronkorken
aber dieses Ding ist wirklich einfach
nur anstrengend und sehr unpraktisch
schwingen fällt es leider durch unser
nächstes Produkt ist ein Problem was wir
alle kennen man geht ins Wasser da sind
Pixi Gesteine man läuft auf dem Sand er
ist viel zu heiß werden diese Schulen
dieses Problem lösen
5.880 Bewertungen und 4,2 Sterne sagen
ja aber mir wollen es selber
herausfinden höchsten sie guck mal wie
weit die Sohle dieser Schuhe ist richtig
geil finde es ja im See immer ziemlich
eklig wenn man dann so auf eigen tritt
und so also bin in Polen auch schon viel
am See gewesen oh gemütlich oh erster
Eindruck ist sehr ich dachte die sind so
hartschal irgendwie aber jetzt wollen
wir mal gucken stellt euch mal vor der
Sand ist so 300 Grad heiß es ist hoch
Sommer und dann lauft ihr so rum nein
ihr stolziert durch den Strand gesagt
hallo macht mir nichts aus nächste
Situation man kennt Matsche dreckige
scheiße auf dem Weg hm will man
eigentlich nicht so berühren mache ich
nicht
meine Schuhe laufen rüber siehst du das
ich spüre nichts Alter und dann stell
mir jetzt einfach mal ins Wasser
irgendwie ein anderes Gefühl also das
Gefühl ist gut es ist irgendwie komisch
Schuhe anzuhaben Strandschuhe damit wir
uns noch mehr der Natur entfernen können
schön praktisch es ist nur eklig wenn
man dann wieder ins Wasser gehen möchte
und dann diesen diesen nassen aber das
ist okay also von mir kriegt das 55
Sterne ist eine tolle Erfindung gerade
für Stadtkinder die sich vor der Natur
ekeln und wenn wir schon mal ins Wasser
gehen wie wäre es mit einer
wasserundurchlässigen Tasche für 7,99 €
lohnt es sich wir machen den Test ihr
habt darauf gewartet
hier ist es stylisch ist diese Tasche ja
schon mal
naja manchmal hat man ja sein Geld dabei
oder sein Handy und das will man ja
nicht am Strand lassen die sind drei so
klippschienen mit denen man das halt
super sicher zu machen kann das war
wirklich kein Wasser durchläuft wir
machen erstmal CEWE Tücher rein Zewa
Tücher es ist einfach der beste Test
weil da sieht man direkt ob ein Tropfen
Wasser reingekommen ist sehr aufwendig
sind wir bereit
ich gehe jetzt einfach mal runter ja
mit der Tasche okay wir waren jetzt
unter Wasser ist mein Hab und Gut
trocken geblieben das ist schon offen
oh trocken ja
das total cool weil dann packst du
einfach dein Autoschlüssel rein dein
paar Geldscheine die du mitgenommen hast
und sogar dein Handy
ja die Frage ist ob das halt wirklich
lange hält schreibt mir mal habt ihr so
eine back ist mal bei euch was passiert
muss man auf irgendwas achten ein Punkt
aber kennt ihr das Problem ihr werdet im
Wasser total müde und wollte euch
einfach mal hinlegen kein Problem mit
den
wasserhängematten wenn das mit dem
Wasser Hängematten funktioniert tschau
für 14,99 und 2er Set das ist ja quasi
nicht aber 189 Leute sagen mit 4,1
Bewertung das ist gut leg dich mal hin
wenn er sagt okay hast mit eurem Müll am
See auf immer gut wegpacken
oh Mann
Alter
funktioniert das wird doch jetzt den
Riesen fail wir werden jetzt den
Reallife Test machen okay wir setz dich
langsam drauf
sie liegt sie liegt kann man machen oder
wie fühlen sie sich dabei
der Film sie mich nicht ich bin hier
privat sie haben mich ins Gesicht
gefilmt das dürfen sie nicht wenn es ein
paar Grad wärmer wäre wärst du schon
sehr angenehm es ist arschkalt
[Gelächter]
und wir fahren mal mit zwei davon das
heißt wir können immer schön Händchen
halten
genug ausgeruht es ist Zeit um etwas zu
spielen ja das ist ein Ball aber das ist
nicht irgendein Ball der das ist der war
Buba und ich habe in den Rezension
gelesen dass nur der war boba-ball toll
übers Wasser springt ist halt so ein
Schaumstoff ne 8,99 € ist ein stolzer
Preis hat aber auch 4,7 Sterne bei 190
Bewertungen ob er wirklich richtig
springt seht ihr wenn wir im See sind
das nächste Produkt musst du mal
ausprobieren
deine echte Golden Retriever Energie
und
als dein Ernst du ja wohl auch
verarschen ey aber das ist was kann der
hat irgendwie besondere Besonderheiten
oder es ist einfach nur ein er soll
übers Wasser richtig schön flitschen und
ditchen zum Werfen oder wie aber wenn
ich ihn jetzt da reinwerfe muss ich ihn
ja wieder rausholen ja dann mach mal
hier so
Richtung zu dir
oh ja würde ich richtig flitzen
Leute jetzt wird gefälscht
voneinander weg steht
mit dem schlechtesten Beitrag
zurück
nee
jetzt aber auch nicht viele andere okay
ich weiß nicht was ich damit dachte vor
zu haben zu wollen es sieht wirklich auf
dem ersten Blick sehr hochwertig aus ich
verrate euch noch nicht was es ist es
kostet 30 Euro und wir testen es jetzt
mal aber es ist gut bewertet 4,7 Sterne
also let's go so man fragt sich nur was
ist das ey wieso bescheuert jetzt habe
ich das sehe das ist so bescheuert aber
das ist im Winter das ist auch das
teuerste dieses Stein im Internet
gesehen aber mich gedacht jetzt wird's
ein bisschen romantisch
okay also es können wirklich nur die
dünnsten Flaschen sein
das ist ja anscheinend schon eine Nummer
zu dick ich schenke uns mal was ein ne
so lässt sich Leben ne ich finde das
fällt halt total durch weil es kann doch
nicht sein dass ja nur eine Größe der
Flasche reinpasst also das ist schon
eine normale Größe
eigentlich eben ich habe extra einen
Flasche ausgesucht wo ich dachte okay
die ist halt schmal weil das bestimmt
nicht so dick ist und ich meine man kann
es dann so machen aber wenn es ein
Korken wäre hätte man es nicht so machen
können ich finde die ganz praktisch weil
die sind ganz schnell in so eine Tasche
geparkt und dann machst du neben deinen
Platz einfach einmal so und dann hast du
immer weg vom Sand mitnehmen
und Weingläser ne also dafür dass das
glaube ich 40 Euro sind wenn man dafür
eine Lösung braucht dann ist es ein
Luxusproblem iPhone 5 aber der Wein ist
tatsächlich eine sehr große Überraschung
das sehr lecker nice meine Damen und
Herren sie kennen das ich bin jetzt
wieder in QVC Stimmung die sind am
Strand und dann ist das Handy alle haben
sie ihre Powerbank aufgeladen natürlich
nicht er denkt denn daran das würde ja
bedeuten dass man vorbereitet im Leben
ist und nicht einfach guckt was der
nächste Tag so bringt aber nicht mit uns
hier ist die Powerbank für die Leute die
zu faul sind zum Aufladen eine Powerbank
mit Solar als ich das gesehen habe habe
ich gedacht ja das ist eine Powerbank
für mich jedes Mal wenn ich unterwegs
bin und sogar meine powerbanks dabei
habe merke ich no die ist sowas von leer
und diese Powerbank lädt sich einfach in
der Sonne ja okay es muss Tag sein
wirklich und die Sonne muss scheinen und
man muss so in der Sonne sein so dass
man halt daran kommt aber dann ist es
die beste Erfindung der Welt glaubt ihr
mir nicht 1000 664 Leute sagen was
anderes und zwar 4,3 Sterne zusammen
35,98 mein Gott Powerbank sind auch echt
teuer ich bin mal gespannt man kennt es
ich brauche einfach Strom aber ich bin
am See wo gibt's hier Strom ist hier
gleich eine Steckdose nein doofe Frage
hört auch sowas zu fragen ja gucken wir
mal ob es funktioniert ne wir sind jetzt
in der Mittagssonne sollte eine gute
Sonne sein
die Frage von überhaupt erkennen dass
sich das auflädt nee
dieses Gerät funktioniert oder
Vertrauensbasis ja da kommt auf jeden
Fall Strom an haha
dann kann man gucken ob es sich
aufgeladen hat ne wir lassen es jetzt
mal hier liegen sechseinhalb Stunden
später nach Ewigkeiten in der Sonne hat
es immer noch nur ein Punkt also ich
glaube das lädt schon aber halt über
Stunden keine Ahnung
vorletztes Produkt ich weiß man könnte
denken Vanessa du bist am See was
möchtest du damit einem Punkt Druck
Wasser zerstreuber aber auch wenn man am
See ist ist ein manchmal im Gesicht warm
das ist der Kapitalismus wie das Buch
geschrieben oh mein Gott mein Gesicht
ist warm nein aber es gibt ja dieses z.B
im jungen Wasser was auch so Duschen
klingt wenn ich das gerade sage aber das
benutze ich gerne im Sommer einfach mal
so zwischendurch um sich zu erfrischen
aber Wasser ist halt es ist von Emilio
diese zersprüher und das ist aus Alu und
sowas muss sein und hier es funktioniert
in der Pumpe man sich das halt ins
Gesicht okay
für 8,44 €. das spritze ich mir das mit
Freude ins Gesicht mit Freude
du merkst ja selber wie heiß ist hier
gerade im Schatten ist ne und der Wind
kühlt uns überhaupt nicht ab das reicht
einfach nicht das ist nicht genug
Punkten
also erstmal Pumpen Punkten Punkten
Punkten und dann abspritzen
aber geiles System ne voll erfrischen
komm her
aber dann aufs Knie okay
komm trotzdem auf dem Bauch
[Musik]
oh mein Gott ich liebe es richtig warm
ist ne
und du draußen unterwegs bist und denkst
geil kannst
weiß ich nicht dicker Strand Gadget ist
mehr so ein City da hat Timo Recht und
das funktioniert ohne Batterie einfach
nur durch Punkten und dann Spritzen
pervers gerade gesagt habe
unser letztes Produkt sollte eigentlich
eine Strandmuschel sein aber entweder
fehlt es mir komplett an Fantasie mir
vorzustellen wie dieses Teil zu einer
großen Sonnenschutz wird oder ich habe
das komplett falsche gekauft das finden
wir jetzt einfach mal gemeinsam am See
heraus
was sind das für das für Haustiere in
Strandmuschel ein paar Sekunden später
das bescheuert warte mal ich guck mal
kurz bei Amazon Timo du glaubst es nicht
es ist wirklich dafür gedacht
doch ja das bin jetzt ich im Zelt das
sieht ganz lustig aus der Timo wie cool
wäre eine große Muschel gewesen ich
hatte mich aber schon gewundert als ich
das gestern gesehen habe dass es
ziemlich klein ist aber es hat so
Seitentaschen für dein Smartphone also
wenn du am Wasser bist und dich jemand
beklauen möchtest nimmt einfach nur
dieses Zelt mit und das waren alle
Produkte ich hoffe ihr hattet Spaß mit
diesem Video und das richtige Fazit
gibt's von Vanessa vom also von Vanessa
vom See so mein Fazit ähm mein Fazit ist
weiß ich nicht was mein Fazit Timo ich
denke nur noch durch Dich ich fand die
Sachen gut die Hängematte fand ich toll
den Ball finde ich super den Spritzer
ist alles ziemlich gute Produkte also
ich wundere mich nicht dass die alle so
eine gute Bewertung haben ich finde
nicht dass man in so viel am Strand
braucht aber so ein oder anderes cooles
Gadget mal dabei zu haben ist so eine
feine Sache und ja ich wünsche euch
einen schönen Sommer tschüss